okay so late so we might as well jump
right to it for Best Picture tonight
here are the nominees American Beauty
whose : Andy Dick Dan Jenks producers
Cider House Rules Richard in Gladstein
producer The Green Mile David Bell Dez
Frank Darabont producers The Insider
Michael Mann and Peter Yanbu gay
produces a sixth sense Frank Marshall
Kathleen Kennedy and Barry Mandel
producing a skirt illness mm-hmm the
Oscar goes to American Beauty
for Bruce Cohen and Dan kinks in the
second
this category for DreamWorks which was
nominated last year the Saving Private
Ryan
it
thank you it was almost exactly two
years ago that Andrew kanava
sent us a screenplay called American
Beauty by Alan Ball it dealt with sex in
drugs
blackmail homophobia infidelity and
suburban dysfunction and in the middle
of all this was a character named Ricky
Fitts who at one point says sometimes
there's so much beauty in the world I
feel like I can't take it and everyone
in the audience knew exactly what he
meant
Alan Bruce and I will forever be
grateful to you for trusting us with
your beautiful words Sam Mendes
thank you so much for taking this script
and bringing it to the screen in such a
brilliant way that audiences around the
world have been moved by this story of
two American families on a personal note
I want to thank Larry Grimaldi david
janolari michael Pissarro all of my
friends my sister Laura and all my
parents who I am so thrilled are here
with me tonight thank you Bruce thank
you to Kevin Spacey the incomparable
Annette Bening and our entire cast you
are all phenomenal and we shared this
with you we shared this with our
spectacular crew two years ago when
others were passing on this wonderful
script DreamWorks stepped up to the
plate we cannot thank enough so many
people they are from Glenn Williamson to
Steven Spielberg for giving us the
creative freedom to make the movie we
wanted to make and then working
tirelessly to market it and distribute
it thanks also to Allen her got to Greg
Jilly and Paul the gang at Spago's my
friends and family mom dad Julie
especially Grammy and finally on behalf
of everyone associated with American
Beauty Dan and I thank the Academy to
receive this extraordinary honor for a
film that we are all so blessed to be a
part of is truly the thrill of a
lifetime thank you thank you
you